okay in our next story
as an example of renewable energy uh in
bitcoin el salvador wants to create a
crypto funded bitcoin city near a
volcano
according to their president
knives
this project is hoping to use the
volcano as a cheap source of geothermal
energy remember back in september el
salvador was the first country to adopt
bitcoin as a national legal tender
whatever that means
the verge noted that this makes it
cheaper and easier for migrants to send
money back home to el salvador and could
improve citizens access to financial
services according to cnbc in 2020 el
salvador received nearly 6 billion in
remittances which was 23 percent of its
gdp so western union and other transfer
fees have a material impact on their
economy yeah you know the craziness here
is
you could lose half your value in
bitcoin right we saw bitcoin have
multiple instances where it went down 25
to 75 percent over the years pullbacks
are the norm do you really want to tie
your currency to that kind of volatility
well
an established stable country does not
want to put themselves on a
decentralized crazy
you know imaginary money store of value
concept here that is uncontrollable but
an emerging country with nothing to lose
that already is dealing with issues
maybe for them it's not such a risk
because they're already in a risky
currency their own
and nbc reported that the bitcoin city
will have residential areas and
commercial areas like restaurants and an
airport okay obviously if it works they
would do that the only tax collected in
the zone will be a value-added tax of
that
so if you don't know what a value-added
tax is because it is far into most
americans investopedia which does a
really good job of defining these things
they define it as a vat is collected on
a product at every stage of its
production during which
value is added to it from its initial
production to the point of sale the
amount of that that the user pays is
based on the cost of the product less
any cost of materials used in the
product that have already been taxed at
a previous stage
uh the value-added tax is a type of
consumption tax obviously uh key
takeaways the value-added tax or vat is
added to a product at every point on the
supply chain or value is added
advocates of that
vats claim that they raise government
revenues without punishing the wealthy
by charging them more through an income
tax critics say that vats place an undue
economic burden on lower income
taxpayers although many industrialized
countries have evaluated taxation the
united states is not one of them so
super super confusing for americans to
understand it to fund the city el
salvador is planning to raise 1 billion
via a bitcoin bond in partnership the
digital assets infrastructure company
block stream according to cnbc the bond
offering would happen in 2022 entirely
in bitcoin
that's a savvy move because all these
people around the world who are bitcoin
advocates and ship their bitcoin to them
pretty easily so it sounds almost like a
dow and a bond is kind of like a dow
when you think about it it's like a
structure uh just not a decentralized
one it's a centralized one 500 million
would be used to purchase bitcoin 500
million will go to harnessing the energy
from the volcano and mining that's a
kind of interesting split i wonder how
they came up with that that when you see
an interesting number split like that
that's indicative of maybe a money grab
and people haven't actually bought this
through like is it exactly 500 million
to get the energy from the volcano
mining like is it 276 thousand 276
million it's really exactly 500 million
and they're just rounding it up where
they're rounding it up to a billion kind
of weird according to block works which
i've never heard of the bitcoin bond
will have special dividends dispersed on
an annual basis generated by the
staggered liquidation of bitcoin so they
will sell bitcoin each year to pay for
their bondholders interestingly el
salvador picked bitfinex securities to
issue the bond the same company behind
tether what could go wrong oh my lord if
you didn't know this uh the new
president of el salvador
uh has a very mixed
reputation
some people consider him a dictator uh
and they
uh think he stole uh power this is
probably not the person that you want to
and he actually refers to himself as the
world's coolest dictator but this is
probably not the person that any project
technology or otherwise would want to
tie themselves to
except for maybe bitcoin laser eyes have
fun staying poor it's pretty toxic to
put yourself in alignment with this
individual but it's going to be an
interesting experiment so i'm i'm i'm
here for it if they are able to raise a
billion dollars in bitcoin from the
bunch of crazy bitcoin you know
billionaires out there and then they get
payback and they're able to build the
city based on it
sure secure the bag el salvador get that
money build 10 cities if you can get 10
billion let's go if you've got other
places to get free energy let's go their
ability to execute on this their
partnership with bitfinex there's so
many red flags here that this looks like
a mini golf location like this is red
flags everywhere stay the heck out of
here
i would not go near this project how is
this better than people just investing
in bitcoin directly is of course what
you'd ask yourself well maybe the bonds
um
will be
more acceptable into the financial
system you know the guy michael saylor
who has the laser eyes from
microstrategy which was i think a failed
company that had a checkered past he
just decided to turn it into
a bitcoin holding company essentially
and he just bought as much bitcoin as
possible he's the guy who famously said
sell everything you own buy bitcoin get
loans buy bitcoin just do everything you
can it's his thesis um which
i'll be honest uh you know he's been
quite right for some period of time uh
when the market pulls back of course he
looks like a [ __ ] and then when the
bitcoin doubles he looks like a genius
and that is the nature of
you know this new imaginary monetary
system that is highly speculative and um
i think fairly obvious to everybody a
bubble some people think it's not a
bubble but they're usually the ones who
have a vested interest in getting the
next person to buy bitcoin and that way
bitcoin has a very mlm nature to it
pretty obvious
once you own bitcoin you really want to
tell people buy it buy a buy listen i
own seven figures worth of bitcoin
bought at 100 to 200 a coin
and but i'm not sitting here telling you
to buy it because
i don't know where it's going to go i
think it could go back down to 30 as
easily as it could go up to 300.
before we get into the ad i want you to
go to linkedin.com twist and post your
first job for free just do that right
now first job posting free linkedin.com
twist okay now on to the admin today
many small business owners are busier
than ever time spent searching for and
interviewing the wrong candidates takes
away from growing your business that's
why linkedin jobs has made it easier to
get the candidates worth interviewing
and you're going to get those candidates
fast and your first job posting is free
in just minutes you can post a job on
linkedin and reach the world's largest
professional network which is now over
770 million people wow they're gonna hit
a billion soon you can use screening
questions to get your role in front of
only the most qualified people then you
can quickly filter and prioritize who
you'd like to interview and hire we love
linkedin jobs at launch and in 2021 we
hired a third producer a curriculum
designer and a couple more researchers
and we're still hiring and linkedin jobs
gets it done for us i love the product
so linkedin jobs helps find you the
right candidates worth interviewing
faster every week nearly 40 million job
seekers visit linkedin and you can post
your job for free at linkedin.com twist
that's linkedin.com twist to post your
first job for free terms and conditions
of course apply because they're giving
you something for free